weißt du was das beste an reza ist dass
du in zukunft noch viel öfter hier sein
wirst von mir aus sehr sehr gerne
dann kann riesa pauken und wir können
quatschen genau aber ich glaube man
bekommt ihr nicht lernen weg nicht an du
das willst du schon sehen was machst du
jetzt mit mag gar nichts mache ich mit
mag
ich treffe endlich bin und dann wird er
sich unsterblich in mich verlieben und
dann wird alles gut
glaubst du das wirklich ein bisschen
weißt du markert vielleicht seine fehler
er ist faul er hat die uni abgebrochen
und das mit seiner freundin ist auch
schief gelaufen
mit anderer hatte recht gehabt wenn ist
vielleicht wirklich ein gespendet nein
das ist unsinn
wer würde mir sonst so e mail schreiben
vielleicht können wir einen neuen termin
ausmachen ich muss dich jetzt endlich
einmal kennenlernen
alles liebe dein bin gut er ist
vielleicht unsichtbar aber ich wollte
seitdem ich dich kenne dann zu diesem
phantom hinterher wie oft hast du
versucht ihn zu treffen
ein paar mal acht oder neunmal
mindestens und wie oft bist du danach
zurück gekommen ohne dass du ihn
getroffen hast acht oder neunmal
der bus kam zu spät es war der falsche u
bahn eingang ein wichtiger termin ist
dazwischengekommen usw
warum ist es nicht einfach sein weil ich
einfach her warum nimmst du dir nicht
das was du kriegen kannst
vielleicht hast du recht da gibt es
immer noch carla du weißt doch gar nicht
was da passiert
hallo alex motto ich habe eine
überraschung für dich eine ganz große
überraschung denn ich bin neugierig das
kannst du auch sein aber du musst dich
noch bis morgen abend gedulden und dann
kommst du ins theatercafé und dann nicht
so spannend und dann lernst du denn